vous savez tous que la cible
shiva est dominante et seulement
la dominante comment savons-nous même que la
fille sera un moine
notre espèce ne remet pas en question les ordres nous les
suivons sergent invoquons leur icône
[Musique]
notre ennemi n'abandonnera pas facilement son cristal mère
cela le fera  sois un combat acharné
tu ne devrais pas être dehors nous en avons
discuté
viens joshua ton père
nous attendra
je suis le bouclier de joshua
j'ai juré de le protéger
notre cause
qu'importe c'est le max
terne qui a repoussé les croisés et la
bataille des royaumes jumeaux
sans la bénédiction du
cristal mère nous ne pouvons pas défendre notre royaume de
la propagation du fléau
[Musique]
les vipères impériales veulent-elles vraiment dire  pour
nous envahir
c'est le fils de l'archiduc
arrête ça
mais c'est impossible
l'héritage des cristaux
a façonné notre
histoire assez longtemps
je te tue
si c'est la dernière chose que je fais